what up space fam goes in here back to
discuss the latest chapter of one piece
and things are really starting to go
down we got more Dragon which is always
great but also we got the reveal of
vegapunk's true dream and a hype rematch
for Luffy so make sure to stay tuned for
this hype chapter be a pirate king and
smash that like button if you enjoyed
these reviews and hit that notification
Bell so you don't miss future ones now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all this chapter is called
a genius's dream which of course speaks
of vegapunk's dream that I've already
mentioned on the cover we fittingly got
two other Geniuses namely Caesar Clown
and then spoke judge the chapter starts
with Punk 4 telling cp0 that they can
return the esper pasafista without
entering he just says issue the return
order and your mission is complete Kaku
says that that's cold-hearted and Rob
Luchi immediately wonders if they have
noticed of course the smartest man in
the world sees the attempt on his life
coming and acts accordingly that would
make sense Kaku in vain tries to
convince a punk to let them in saying
it's been a long journey and they're
cold even asking for a cup of tea or
something Rob Lucci after verifying
vegapunk's identity asks about The
Disappearance here in Egghead in the
past two months not one government ship
has returned and Lucci asks why the
response is that All Ships as departures
were confirmed this is one of those
classic back and forths where both sides
know what's up but they're still trying
to follow formalities and pretend like
it's all cool of course thankfully the
smartest man in the world is not that
gullible and thankfully he has a Yahoo
crew on his side now to protect them and
just in time it's fun to see how
different personalities react
differently Lilith is fuming that
they're implying that the punks laid
hands on those ships while Pythagoras
simply says relax to Lilith and that cp0
should please leave Rob Lucci of course
is not taking no for an answer he
decides they'll abandon the ship and fly
towards the island using the pacifista's
flight abilities he's aware that the sea
beasts will destroy his ship when they
invade I like how he's literally in a
sense burning the boats here so they
either get what they want or die now
that oda's removed the possibility of
cp0 just retreating on their ship you
know something big is about to go down
and I'm hyped for it interestingly
enough at the Grand line the real Kuma
uses his power to disappear to Dragon
surprise where is he going it would be
weird if he wasn't using his powers to
get the Egghead at this point where
everything is going down and where his
daughter is since we know well that
vegapunk is pretty much a good guy now
it's not hard to believe that vegapunk
didn't completely erase Kuma's will and
he's probably acting on his own will now
although he better not get recaptured
after everything the revolutionaries did
just saying and finally we come to
Luffy's group who are with the original
vegapunk he explains that it's been good
but now the number of helpers and funds
he's getting from the world government
is no longer enough he then goes into
his dream which to me definitely seems
to be inspired by the scientist Nicholas
Tesla as we'll get to especially the
idea of everyone having free energy he
says one day I want to create a kind of
world with science a world where energy
is widespread all over the world free of
charge Luffy is oblivious as usual
picking his nose and I love it when
showing protagonists do that and
wondering what that would accomplish
he's probably thinking if you're not
giving meat to everyone then what's the
point but vegapunk elaborates saying the
resources that produce energy are fought
over by many countries and that becomes
the seed for war he explains you can
feel energy here over there and
everywhere else even though the world is
full of it if I can convert it to
visible power he says to large views of
War will be erased from the world and
back to Tesla that idea of using
invisible energy all around us and
making it visible through electricity
and stuff like wireless light bulbs
definitely makes me think that Oda got
some of this stuff from Tesla himself
who everyone said was way ahead of his
time vegapunk says surely science will
reach that point one day although part
of me still thinks people will find
reasons to have War besides Energy but
at least they'll have less reasons
anyways as vegapunks proclaiming his
dream we get an absolutely amazing panel
making him look like he's Heaven Sent I
absolutely love the setup of this pen
and it's a very nice idea to that
vegapunk has especially since science
can often lead to worse damage during
Wars because of Advanced Technology
being able to cause more damage with
less effort he's definitely an idealist
and I'm glad he's not just an amoral
scientist who doesn't care what happens
as long as he progresses science I like
that his goals piece and it makes sense
that he gets along with the also peace
driven Dragon also I'm definitely seeing
the Albert Einstein similarities in some
of these panels look wise the idea is
like I said mostly remind me of Tesla
but look wise definitely Vega bunker
mines with Albert Einstein and I love
how Oda draws from everything for
inspiration including fiction and
non-fiction nothing is off limits Lu
Luffy for his part doesn't seem moved he
explains that he thinks a person that
can make everyone happy is good but he's
not interested in being a hero though
and it's funny that he keeps saying this
while continuing to act rather
heroically in situations like wano where
he wants to help and protect the people
it makes him all the more likable though
because he does the good stuff but is
not conceited or on a high horse about
it and it also gives him the rebel
appeal that pirates should have which
makes me love him all the more megapunt
goes on to explain that he's seeking the
energy that Dynamic power source that
was able to power the ancient robot
Soldier he's gotten close to finding out
about that ancient energy he wonders if
he unravels the strings of the Forbidden
history what on Earth will he be able to
comprehend he says in the course of
inheriting his friend's will he is
quickly getting close to the truth and
just then bam an explosion happens which
of course is cp0 getting closer Vega
Punk realizes that he's running a of
time so he concludes that in short he
stepped too deep into the Forbidden
story so he will be eliminated by the
world government just like what they did
to Ohara I really like how in this way
Oda Hypes up the importance of knowledge
and history so much to the point where
people will do anything to stop you from
figuring it out and of course it makes
the mystery all the more intense and
intriguing it's explained to Luffy that
cp0 those who act only under orders of
the celestial dragons and that they are
at the top of cyberpole I'm really
excited to see an old villain that Luffy
beat up pop up again and stay relevant
that's another thing I love about one
piece how the villains can continue to
grow strengthwise along with the
protagonist and that definitely goes for
Blackbeard too however I still don't see
Rob Lucci being able to beat yonko Luffy
so I'm interested in seeing where Oda
plans to take this not surprisingly
Usopp is freaking out when they realize
that Rob Luchi and the rest made it
inside Rob was right about the Sea Beast
destroying their ship so it looks like
this has to come to a head I'm excited
to see Punk one AKA Daft Punk as I like
to call him preparing to release
seraphim s snake s hock and S shark for
battle considering what we've seen from
them so far I feel like cp0 shouldn't be
able to just Breeze through these next
level pacifista versions of boa mihawk
and jimbei so right now it really seems
like our side is heavily favored so
finally we get the request of vegapunk
he asks if the straw hats will take him
out to the Sea after he packs his
belongings this is hyped for a bunch of
reasons and not just for the reasons I
already mentioned many reviews ago about
vegapunk being a potential Straw Hat
also think about how much more notorious
Luffy would be if he was Sheltering
someone as potentially dangerous to the
world government as vegapunk man if the
world government was being honest
Luffy's bounty would be the highest ever
no doubt if he did that fortunately for
me who really wants to see vegapunk join
the crew at least for a Time Luffy
agrees to take vegapunk with him and his
reasoning is Flawless he comments that
vegapunk has a funny looking head so he
guesses it's fine and unlike Chopper I
am not at all surprised by his selection
standards vegapunk then tells them to
bring Bonnie and move up to the labo
phase above the clouds before
disappearing himself after they are
confronted with some Holograms cp0
Stussy reveals that she's been here
before in fact she finds it all
nostalgic we get Hilarious Moments where
she keeps failing to warn Kaku about
things in time like the fact that he's
about to kick a hologram and then the
fact that he's about to get laser beamed
when he crosses the line into the
frontier Dome she says after the fact
that they shouldn't underestimate the
world's number one scientist while Rob
Lucci begs her to say things beforehand
love to see even antagonists having
well-developed and funny group dynamics
then Punk Atlas attacks them even though
Daft Punk tells her she's no match for
them Rob Lucci finally snaps saying this
is not a game and he crushes Atlas even
Kaku is like brah no mercy at all eh
considering that atlas's toughness was
previously emphasized this serves to
further hype up Rob luchi's new powers
Rob Lucci notices that Atlas is still
breathing before he sees Luffy running
and also narrating what he's about to do
namely go up using the vacuum rocket and
we get a perfect moment as they make eye
contact with Rob Lucci comments straw
hat and Luffy comments pigeon guy
we're told there will be no break next
week and that a Fateful Encounter has
taken place once again again I am super
interested in seeing where this goes now
since Luffy obviously has already beaten
this dude and gotten way way stronger
since then even if Rob Lucci has gone
stronger too I think we should all be
waiting to see what Kuma will do as well
that will definitely be relevant another
thing to consider is that the
revolutionaries May well follow Kuma
there and so we could get that epic
Straw Hat revolutionary Alliance going
sooner than expected like I've been
saying we need and I think it's close
since obviously Luffy and dragon and
their people would get along really well
at this point especially with their Vega
Punk connection very interesting stuff
right now and let me know what you
thought about it how you like this
chapter and what do you think is going
to happen next smash that like button if
you're a pirate king and enjoy this
chapter let me know if you actually see
cp0 in this situation posing any kind of
threat now smash that like button if
you're a pirate king and enjoy this
chapter smash that notification Bell to
get notified When Future chat reviews
come out be sure to check out my one
piece playlist link on screen and in the
description where I cover a bunch of One
Piece topics including an hour-long
video about Shanks videos about all the
yonko Warlords Admirals and much more
link to that is in the description and
also I just must say huge
congratulations to Japan who just beat
Spain and are now advancing into the
next stage of the FIFA World Cup I feel
like we're witnessing an IRL Sports
Shonen right now anyways until the next
exciting chapter of One Piece see you
Space Cowboys